hey this is pressure Locker a lot of
people are arguing over the correct
answer to this algebra problem on
Facebook
this post has over five hundred thousand
comments can you figure it out give it a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video I'm going to explain the
correct answer in order to solve this
problem you have to look very closely at
the pictures the first trick is that in
the third line there are two horseshoes
versus in the fourth equation there is
just one horseshoe the other difference
is that the third line has two boots
whereas the fourth line has only one
boot so taking these things into account
let's find the correct value to the last
expression the first equation is that
three horses are equal to 30 we can
divide both sides of the equation by
three to get that one horse is equal to
ten we now look at the next equation we
can replace the horse with the value of
ten we can then subtract 10 from both
sides to get that some number of
horseshoes is equal to eight we count
that there are four horseshoes equal to
eight which means one horseshoe is equal
to two this brings us to the third
equation we have two horseshoes minus
two boots equal to we can replace the
two horseshoes by the value of 2 times 2
which is 4 we then a 4 minus something
is equal to 2 that means the two boots
have to have a value that's equal to 2
we therefore have two boots equal to 2
which means one boot is equal to 1 so we
now have that the boot is equal to one
the horseshoe is equal to 2 and the
horse is equal to 10 we need to evaluate
boot plus the horse times a horseshoe we
substitute in these values and
get one plus ten times two the last
thing we have to remember is we have to
follow the order of operations
multiplication should take precedence
over addition ten times two is equal to
20 we then take 1 plus 20 and that's
equal to the correct answer of 21 did
you figure it out thanks for watching
this video please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math and game
theory you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there links in
the video description